les Chéries tout le monde va bien est-ce
que si vous avez quelque chose à dire
dites-le maintenant taisez-vous à tout
jamais c'est bon merci voilà je peux
enlever ma Vaisse j'ai chaud
oui oui enlève ta va on va devoir
enlever ton micro et
ceteraas la prochaine pub d'accord ça te
dérange pas c'est tout ce que tu as dire
tu veux pas parler d'actualité
télévision ENF je bien ou oui allez-y
dis-moi un truc allez-y non non mais je
vous écoute je vous suis elle est dans
votre r le
niveauis chaud
ouach chaud chaud franchement mais égar
merci allez on vapt c'est
parti
commentz-vous bien j'ai mise pour toi
très beau ça c'est c'est c'est une
petite nouveauté quoi des marrons
Glac c'est la nouveauté Auton hiver quoi
on est en aut tuimes bien non mais on va
pas parler de ça allez t' mer de P bon
vous savez je décripe toute l'actualité
avec l'intelligence artificielle et on
commence comme toutes les semaines avec
la Deep fake news en gros j'invente une
info totalement folle totalement fausse
et je pars à la rencontre des gens pour
voir ce qu'ils en pensent qu'est-ce qui
se passe tu la veux c'est un beau vaiss
moi je te la donne he passe mon camion
si tu
veux c'est le camion qui va
avec non mais j'étais pas trop sûr tu
vois je me suis dit j'essaye quoi qui
t'a donné ça c'est Cathy je l'embrasse
styliste oui à mon avis elle t'aime pas
tu pens qu'il y a un délire ou tu penses
qu'elle va me saboter non mais non c'est
elle elle t'a dit ouais j'ai un bail
pour toi c'est elle m'a dit j'ai une
petite pépite tu vas kiffer de ouf
fais-moi confiance elle m'a dit vas-y
les yeux fermés c'est mon métier on
dirait un Ferrero Rocher tu dis ça parce
que je suis gros non pas du tout je te
jure
truc
déconn ça va pas changer ça va être
drôle quand même donc la fausse info que
j'ai inventé par exemple là c'est
Olivier verrant qui l'a dit cette
semaine et oui beaucoup de gens qui se
plaignent de la SNCF c ça peut arriver
et ben maintenant s'il y a des gens en
grève des conducteurs en grève et ben
c'est vous qui allez conduire le train
voyez vous ici ouis oui si vous en avez
marre comme ça vous allez l'emmener à
destination j'ai fait croire ça des gens
dans la rue ça donne ça
[Musique]
regardez et bien sachez que maintenant
lorsqu'il y aura une grève de conducteur
à la SNCF vous pourrez conduire le train
vous-même pour arriver à destination
comme ça plus de conducteur en grève car
le conducteur ça sera vous c'est une
blague donc en fait on va conduire les
trains nous-mêmes si jamais il y a une
grève c'est ça vous en pensez quoi c'est
une bonne mesure mais bien sûr que
non c'est c'est n'importe quoi c'était
aujourd'hui ça et les filles vous êtes
au courant là de Olivier Verant ce qu'il
a dit ce matin je suis avec la télé
là conducteur en gr car conducteur ça
sera beau matin il a dit ça ce matin non
mais franchement quelle compétence j'ai
pour pouvoir conduire un métro ou
conduiser une voiture allez opérer un
monsieur aussi un chirurgien le hein il
est chirurgien vous êtes chirurgien
monsieur si on vous dit d'aller au bloc
alleer opérer quelqu'un je j'ai regardé
Grace Anatomy bah voilà par exemple je
sais tout de suite s'il faut percer un
trou dans la carotide que c'est là non
c'est pas là la carotide ah bon c'est là
ah ouais c'est pas grave ok Z voyez non
c'est un ministre qui dit ça non mais
attendez non je vous promet c'est c'est
c'est où est-ce qu'on va quoi qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez c'est un imbécile
c'est tout et voilà c'est dit écoute on
a République on peut c'est pas grave
j'ai le droit ils vont pas m'emprisonner
hein c'est pas la peine d'avoir fait
lesena pour sortir des anneries
pareilles qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
de cette décision bon ben c'est
n'importe quoi c'est n'importe quoi
laisse-nous tranquille tu étais au PS
après tu es passé avec macran et puis là
tu nous emmerdes bah oui franchement
vous pourrez conduire le train vous-même
pour arriver à
[Musique]
destination et il a fumé ce matin j'en
sais rien ben on est il est sous LSD je
vais pas me prendre des responsabilité
d'avoir 100 personnes derrière moi alors
que j'ai jamais conduit un train je
connais pas tous les enguillages
c'est aiguillage bien sûr bien sûr on
l'embrasse très long et bien sûr c'est
pas vrai parce qu' des gens qui arrivent
Olivier dit ça bien sûr c'est faux non
c'est l'intelligence artificielle bon
cette semaine j'ai décidé de
m'intéresser au JT au JT de France 2
avec le magnifique laurend laousse je
sais pas qui est le plus beau d'ailleurs
c'est ton délire laurend laous euh ouais
c'est pas mal il est pas mal il est
assez sexy moins que vous mais il estand
Mme tu as failli faire la boulette non
mais il peut ah non mais c'est pas c'est
la p vérit non non mais toi tu tu tu
l'aimes bien non trop propre
non si tu aimes les
mec c'est pas la même
chauvelure non trop
propre non pas du tout
alr ça c'est vraimentes vraent mais moi
je le dis des années il peut me supper
trouve trop
Liss d'abord je préfère les brins un peu
peu ça reste un bel homme bien qu-ce que
tu veux Daniel est en train de N dire
Jean Le Poulin est plus beau
[Musique]
ques lisse
problème je demande
pas j'espère que ça va pas être à mon
tour mais mais mais ça faut pas déconner
mais même moi je pourrais en tout cas il
est très joli ou pas avec ce
blouson en tout cas avec l'intelligence
artificielle j'ai modifié légèrement les
reportages que vous avez l'habitude de
voir et du coup c'est beaucoup mieux
regardez
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce JIT du
mtivers en bref dans l'actualité
d'aujourd'hui l'étonnante recomersion de
Jean la qui quitte la politique pour se
lancer dans une nouvelle aventure celle
de
[Applaudissements]
TikTok bon du coup j'ai continuer de
regarder en avançant un petit peu je me
suis rendu compte que ça parla aussi
d'un chroniqueur de TPM exusivité nos
équip plus suivre Jean-Michel mer ne
touche pas à mon poste en boîte de nuit
et c'est confirmé il ne boit pas que de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'eau et juste après il s'est mis à
parler d'un des plus grands cuisiners de
France phipbes le meilleur ouvrier de
France et animateur prépare activement
la nouvelle saison de Top Chef pour être
au top le jour de la
[Rires]
première
et il a même parlé dans son JT de la
maman d'un animateur très connu regardez
et enfin une partie de la France est
bloquée par le froid découvrez le cri du
cœur d'Odette la maman d'un certain
Patrick Sébastien madame vous sortez
vous allez où
je cher et ce matin aller chercher son
pain est une opération périlleuse pour
tout le monde
pas et pour finir on a vu un grand
format sur la vie privée de quelqu'un
qui est autour de cette table et ça m'a
vraiment choqué qui inspirit le film 40
ans toujours plus haut c'est l'émouvant
Raymon Abou connu sur le nom de
l'abominable de Ragis nous l'avons suivi
dans son quotidien de solitude un
reportch
ber en grand fan de Star Wars il
s'inspire bien souvent de ce film C pour
s'imaginer le jour où il passera
[Musique]
à qui
em la
princesse ça doit être un moment
magnifique je suis désolé r Je suis
désolé pas mal pas malanch est beau mal
cy petite nouveauté cette semaine j'ai
envie de tenter quelque chose avec
l'intelligence artificielle j'ai décidé
de créer une série de toutes pièces vous
connaissez tous les Experts à Miami j'ai
voulu créer les experts à Gerba alors
c'est pas les mêmes acteurs j'ai dû
prendre des acteurs un peu moins chers
mais voici ce que ça donne et cyil
attention à la fin il y a même un
policier du RA hyper connu que tu aimes
bien qui vient souvent ici
c'est
[Applaudissements]
parti 1 2 4 3 et 5 et c'est bien 5 après
de 3
non ça m'a donné mal à ma
têtek 1 2 3 4 tu es vraiment une ga
l'inspecteur lar va monter en l'air
ouais tu crois que je suis fort en mat
ou quoi et puis l'pectur lar il sont
Carion de l'enquête il est trop occupé à
essayer de tremper sa brialf dans la
charba
Jennifer
[Musique]
tu as vu je me suis acheté un card tu
pens j mais tu'es Vè
de je compr que vous
trou jeos matin que tu res tu viens
prendre un bus dans la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
test ce que moi je vais appeler les
copains du SPIP tu vois ça va pas
rigoler longtemps bah franchement j'en
ai marre à force de dormir sur la
béquille je me transformer en mobylette
[Applaudissements]
moiement
bon votre nouvelle série événement
pourra faire d'autres épisodes
unear qu'est-ce qu'il va faire là P pour
finir alors pour finir Cyril je sais que
vous aimez ça la chanson et là vous
allez être servi avec l'intelligence
artificielle j'ai récupéré les vrais
clips et j'ai changé la tête des
chanteurs ça donne ça c'est une spéciale
TPMP regardez découvrez la compile TPMP
quand le plus beau pif du PAF rencontre
une jury de The Voice ça donne zasis
Verdez
soyons fr les vein
soyons le plus célèbre chauffeur de C8
rencontre la plus célèbre rappeuse du
monde ça fait diam son à bout ah ouais
on dé oua ouais on est non non c'est pas
les PO qui nous a no C non non
[Musique]
quand un représentant du barreau fait un
tour sur La Canière ça fait
NAS et quand la pépite de Tunis
rencontre le roi de la pop ça fait asis
Jackson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bisous tout le
mondeelel c'est énorme